you started your your presidency in 1992
Andy and I started doing this show in in
1993 and and so I have some appreciation
for in that span of time how much things
have changed now you were out there
campaigning hard last year at this time
you probably I'm curious did you think
you saw a different America than the one
that you had seen when you were
campaigning back in 1992 do you think we
have profoundly changed since then yes
and no that is I think the good news is
and I know it's hard to see and was
totally unfashionable to talk about in
1990 in 2016 but the country is much
more diverse than it used to be and I
think that's a good thing we are still
we are still compared to other wealthy
countries relatively young and having
lost that I can tell you youth matters
that is the relative the median age of
the workforce is a big deal in terms of
the economic potential of a country so
and since the birth rate of native-born
Americans of all races is just barely a
replacement level we need immigrants to
come in and keep diversifying the
country but that's better now
so the thing that's not so good is that
we're in the middle of revolution that
yeah well there is that I'm sorry sir we
know believe me I know especially yeah
but anyway we're in the middle of this
transition of how we get our information
how we communicate and the the pattern
of economic growth has heavily favored
people with more education and heavily
pay for people without regard to their
education level if they live in or
around cities that are growth centres so
for example in the last election
President Trump on all these rural
counties they comprised he got 46
percent of the vote they comprised 36
percent of the GDP of the country the
counties Hilary carried comprised 64
percent of GDP of the country even
though the median income of a Trump
voter was slightly higher than the
median income of a Hillary voter the
people who voted for her were people who
were hopeful about the future believed
in the assets a country believe we could
grow together and go together
and with some help and we're basically
more resistant to the bizarre nature of
the way the election was covered they
just looked at the debates and they
looked at the conventions and they made
a choice and so I think that what all of
us have to do is no matter how happy
some of us are about what happened
yesterday in the elections we have to
remember that the founders told us our
job was to create a more perfect union
so we have to bridge these economic
divides just like we asked the people on
the other side of the social divide to
help us bridge the social divide we have
to create an inclusive economic
inclusive societies and we need an
inclusive culture
and then we need to tell all these
people that just make up stuff on the
internet - knock it off that we're
voting for people who are going to do
jobs these are jobs and soon as somebody
gets one of these jobs you find out
pretty quick that the decisions they
make have consequences that affects
people's lives and so it matters what
you know and even more important it
matters how you think whether you're
conservative or liberal do you believe
this is an interdependent age and we
can't escape each other then you got to
decide which is more important our
interesting differences are common
humanity and that's the conclusion I
draw but it is different and it's way
better in some ways and much more
troubling in some ways yeah and the
dictators Club in the world and there's
a bunch of them you know they want two
things they want nuclear weapons because
they feel like they can ever be
dislodged no matter how much people hate
them if they got nuclear power and they
want to abolish the line between fact
and fiction and truth and lie because
they figure if you don't know what's
true and you don't think you can ever
know that pretty soon everybody will
accept the fact that democracy is no
longer possible right I like foreign
countries now we're here because I that
chilled me to the bone for a second I
thought we were in Korea look all I can
tell you you just said a lot by saying
nothing
no but look at the effort here to
disenfranchise voters to make it harder
for young people for people of color for
the elderly and firm who are poor and
vulnerable for all kinds of people to
vote just the reason there's no
immigration reform is because the people
who are against it are afraid it would
adversely affect their electoral
prospects if more people who work in pay
taxes could also vote and when the
Supreme Court gutted the Voting Rights
Act they made a terrible mistake because
it unleashed all these efforts to
basically try to shrink the electorate
but those of you who don't like it
should own some responsibilities if you
have ever missed a midterm election yeah
because that's the most of the governor
that elected that's in most of the
secretary the latest lady's reelected we
all got to own up here we need to just
go out and start going up to people who
are mad at us it's like look let's get
over it we got to live together we got
to share this together and if we work
together we'll have better economics
will have better societies and we'll
have a culture that we can all be proud
you